[Music]
thank you as it was
I know it's not the same but it was
right
on
times
[Music]
it wouldn't be music's biggest night
without some show-stopping performances
we're going from one performance to the
next now E.T is breaking down the artist
taking the stage at the 65th annual
Grammy Awards you get a little nervous
but once you're out there you know
you're just singing you do what you do
first up Mary J Blige who is nominated
for six Awards including record of the
Year album of the Year and best r b
performance
Bad Bunny is up for best pop solo
performance and best musica Urbana album
[Music]
safe to say he'll bring the party I'm
very grateful that the world uh can
connect with my music I'm very grateful
for that delivering style to the Grammy
stage Harry Styles
[Music]
the musician is nominated in six
categories including album record and
song of the year as well as best solo
performance best pop vocal album and
best music video
take us
[Music]
six-time Grammy winner Brandi Carlisle
who is nominated for seven Awards this
year including best rock performance
best Americana performance and best
Americana album is set to blow us away
[Music]
meanwhile lizzo who has five Noms
including song of the Year and best pop
vocal album is sure to slay we've been
killing it and now we get to kill it on
the Mainstays fans can expect a sultry
moment from Sam Smith and Kim Petrus who
are up for Pop Duo group performance for
their hit song Unholy
[Music]
Steve Lacy will bring the Vibes with his
performance Sunday night he's nominated
in four categories including best pop
solo performance for his breakthrough
hit bad habit
[Music]
[Applause]
rounding out the star-studded lineup
Luke Combs who might sweep the country
genre with three nominations
foreign
[Music]
so we'll just have to wait and see who
takes home Grammy gold but one thing's
for sure the performances will have us
feeling good or as lizzo would put it
good as hell